I am now Inchon the editor of Yale
global online and we have in our studio
to returning to our studios Martin wolf
the chief economics writer for Financial
Times Martin welcome back it's pleasure
to be here again and Martin very pleased
to have in my hand your latest book
fixing global finance no other title
could be more appropriate for these days
so it's very nice to have you Martin
with us I thought since you we have you
here and works foremost expert on the
financial issues might actually use this
opportunity to have you give us a primer
on the crisis that is roiling the world
to start with first of all how does one
explain that american mortgage holders
failure to pay their mortgage could
create such a house in the world leading
to banks failing including a government
like in iceland toppled over because of
that so how do you explain it well it is
in a way quite difficult to explain and
easy important to stress that I at least
and there were others who did much
better did not foresee a catastrophe of
this scale and even now their immense
debates among serious observers
economists and financial experts what
precisely has caused such enormous havoc
I think we have some sense of what led
up to it and some sense of how it works
but there are some real uncertainties
which I'll come to in a moment so let us
first start with what led up to it my
view is somewhat developed from what was
in the book which was finished more than
a year ago is that there were really two
principle underlying drivers of the deep
underlying forces the first has been
really quite long term three decades of
expansion of the financial sector and
particularly growth of credit and debt
and of the balance sheet of the
financial sector its total assets
a completely unprecedented rate so if
you take for example the balance sheet
of the US financial sector it's been
growing on average about six times
faster than u.s. GDP since the early 80s
and that was actually accelerating in
this last decade ha what happened why
did this acceleration tech lesson time
well this is in fact related to the
second thing I think that that most of
this expansion was at least up to the
late 1990s was because after the 70s
which had been a big air of inflation
inflation really wipes out debt so in
the early 80s it was very little debt in
the economy we liberalised finance there
was a new environment of low inflation
and stability people borrowed more and
merely by the act of borrowing more they
create credit that's how it works the
banking balance sheet expands they find
new creditworthy borrowers the only real
constraint on expanding the balance
sheet for the financial system is its
solvency to underline perceived solvency
and it was perceived to be very solvent
so it expanded steadily but I think in
the late 1990s and early 2000s something
changed and this is the second cause
which I really focus on the global
imbalances issue which is that for a
number of reasons that are quite
complicated I probably don't have the
time to go through right now the
emerging economies of the world
particularly in East Asia emerged as
vast surplus savings countries they ran
huge current account surpluses which
means they had an excessive savings
looking for a home and first that drove
down real interest rates world why he
begat very low secondly the home turned
out to be principally the u.s. the u.s.
emerged it had been a small deficit
country before them but it emerges a
huge deficit country in this decade as
the surpluses in China and other Asian
countries later the oil exporters
exploded now if you started so this
capitalist capital came into the u.s. it
was invested largely in foreign currency
reserves so very liquid assets which
were invested is
eventually in the US market a lot of it
went to buy the liabilities of Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac as it happens which
were part of this they provided an
extraordinary liquidity base which could
be on let and it also provided an
environment of very low real interest
rates which made it very attractive for
people to create what I think of as
pseudo high yielding safe assets because
of these background conditions the very
low renal interest rates the flood of
money availability that began to be a
series of housing bubbles across much of
the developed world and there was a very
big one here in the context of a housing
bubble go back to my story about credit
well house prices are rising all the
time so it seems completely safe you
borrow against the house even if you
don't have much money it's quite safe
because next year the house will be
worth more and then you if you have
difficulty in servicing the debt you can
always sell the house so it's not a
problem it's in fact it began to become
obvious not just in the US the same
happened in the UK in Spain that you
couldn't lose money borrowing for a
house and then that led to the final
stage at this sort of capstone of this
combination these housing bubbles linked
to these two phenomena they started
creating all these very clever as
securitized as it's very complicated
assets bundling together mortgages which
seemed to provide safe high yielding
assets just what everybody wanted and
they started selling them all over the
world not about half of the US assets
related this bubble ended up all over
the world now if you look now in
retrospect it seems to me pretty clear
it's this combination of events which by
2006 roughly the peak of the housing
bubble had primed the situation for
disaster and the disaster of course
happened when house prices started to
fall when everything basically unworld
and they suddenly discovered bad all
these bad assets so the the whole sort
of borrowings spree was based on the
assumption that the house prices are
always going to go up indeed and so and
when that gave away the whole thing came
coming down yes well
the fact of course that there was simply
so much credit I mean household debt in
the US and the UK doubled over 10 years
to levels that has never been seen
before so you have a hugely
over-indebted household sector you have
a hugely expanded financial sector with
very little equity because nobody
thought it was needed because it was all
saved and a lot of it was pinned against
these complicated securities based on
the assumption that house prices could
only rise and lots of American
economists a Bob Shiller here at Yale
was an exception but lots of American
economists I spoke to said that it was
impossible for highest prices to fall
across the country because they never
fallen it was quite normal view sensible
people for this of course it turned out
they were utterly wrong and then of
course you can you get a vast quantity
of impaired assets and nobody knows how
these new securities which have very
opaque structures are actually going to
work what they're going to be worth once
the underlying assumption about house
prices and therefore the ability to
resell houses and difficulty turned out
to be wrong we also discovered of course
and we know that in a late bubble phase
completely normal lending standards was
lowered its that's not new and a result
a lot of people received houses again
not just in the US also in the UK who
really couldn't afford the loans once
the house prices fell they were
insolvent so again this this bubble was
also partly fueled by the savings of the
East European countries they went my
view yes absolutely putting their money
in the u.s. buying Treasuries and
resulting in lower interest rate this
was what was Ben Bernanke described in a
very famous
speech she gave I think about five years
ago the savings glut hypothesis of what
was going on in the world and my book
explain actually I was thinking about
this before him I wrote about it even
earlier in the two thousand and I had
been very concerned about the effect of
this savings glut for a long period and
the main reason I was so concerned I
didn't expect the complete collapse of
the financial system but was because if
you looked at the US economy it turned
out that a counterpart of the excess
savings in the rest of the world was
accessed boring particularly by the
household sector the u.s. household
sector in the middle of this decade was
running an unprecedented financial
deficit as was to say was spending more
than its income by an unprecedented Lee
large amount and borrowing vast amounts
both to finance that and to finance the
assets they were purchasing whose prices
were clearly in a bubble mode this I
thought was a great source of fragility
I stressed that in my book is one of the
sources of fragility associated with the
imbalances and he turned out that turned
out to be correct and the the other side
of the same coin is this Chinese huge
trade surplus that is correct when the
u.s. household is going into debt and
what they're buying is often the
products from China that is correct and
so the Chinese became an almost
deliverer of sellers credit they are
giving much with us so that the u.s. can
then go and splurge yeah that is correct
and then the finance you might call
right that was part of the mechanism
they bought us treasuries right and the
counterpart of that you know they were
financing it away their own exports lot
of which we're going to the US right so
now explain to us how did this housing
bubble burst in the u.s. spread so fast
to the rest of the world what's the
mechanism well this is is an interesting
and it's where it's also become so
disturbing i I think there were two
aspects of this first as I've already
mentioned about half of the securitized
obligations the CEOs collateralized debt
obligations and the CDO squared the
these very complicated legations have
actually been sold abroad a lot of them
to European banks the European banks
were also looking for high-yielding safe
as it and they were ended up all over
the world some European banks actually
bought us subsidiaries which were
actively engaged in household lending
but the very big british-based bank hsbc
is an example of a european bank that
had bought a US mortgage lender but
others just bought all these securities
about half of them ended up abroad so
that was one reason why this became
global almost at once it became obvious
that these assets were everywhere indeed
one of the worst-hit banks in the world
by this was UBS the Swiss bank which had
a very active brick American subsidiary
which was deeply involved in this and
ended up with an enormous exposure which
is why the Swiss government has had to
rescue it but that's only one thing the
second thing that you have to remember
and this point I stress quite frequently
reason is that the financial system of
the world in the last 10-15 years did
truly become global the big players of
the world the big financial institutions
particularly the West all operate
globally they all have American
subsidiaries and European subsidiaries
and they're all interconnected very
closely connect interconnected totals Oh
elevation of the globalization of the
financial system was extreme so once any
significant institution gets into
trouble and the most famous such case of
course is lehman the third largest of
the investment banks in the world got
into trouble hello Lehman is a global
firm it does business or did business
all over the world and it did business
with everybody you know it did business
with any major banking institution you
can manage imagine and with hedge funds
everywhere so of course once lehman to
take this very salient an important
example went under in middle of
September of last year it affected the
opp confidence in counterparties
everywhere
because everybody was dealing with
everybody else so there was no longer a
national financial system the u.s.
didn't have a national financial system
neither the British are indeed very much
not well over half of the assets of our
banking system are foreign assets and
liability you talked about Iceland well
Iceland was an extreme example of that
most of the Iceland is a tiny country
with a few hundred thousand people so
nearly all the assets and liabilities of
the Icelandic banking system which
exploded in size to almost 10 times GDP
its assets and liabilities nearly all of
these were abroad they were part of the
global system Icelandic people couldn't
rescue this once the assets went down
this these institutions were insolvent
and no government could save them so
once this one of the things we've learnt
in fact is that a significant crisis
affecting an important class of assets
like housing relating related securities
immediately becomes global because all
the institutions have invested in them
and all the institutions are doing
dealing with all the others so I don't
think it can you can possibly imagine
anymore and national financial crisis is
one of the most important lessons of the
whole mess there's one final thing of
course once the financial system is
impaired it doesn't lend anymore it's
too frightened to lend to anybody and
that was particularly severe in
September and thereafter of course it
affects the rest of the economy nobody
can borrow business can't borrow
governments can't borrow corporations
big even the safest corporation
Scarborough so you then have a crisis in
credit which effects in fact the entire
world you know the emerging economies
are affected consumers are affected so
they don't spin and that's of course why
in the last few months we moved into a
global recession which some people for
thing cover it's a depression simply
because recently the decline in GDP for
some countries you know have been so
very very severe I mean Japan for
example has the last quarter as i
understand it has had a negative growth
at an annualized rate of ten percent and
and similar things are being seen in
other East Asian countries
back there particularly badly it China's
growth in the last quarter was probably
zero which for China is a depression
right so it's certainly worse than a
conventional recession and unless it
turns round fairly soon it's going to
feel worse than anything since the 30s
and I think this is how we got here it's
a global system which was built on a
global causes but very very large
regulatory and other mistakes in various
countries and particularly the u.s. so
the one of basic diesel equilibrium that
invention is the high ceilings in China
and high indebtedness in the United
States this disequilibrium how can one
resolve let or at least narrow the gap
in the current situation you may you
wrote I think yesterday that or last
week that the Chinese growth should be
ten percent a year and China's domestic
expenditures with twelve percent in
order for this gap to be narrowed this
is this realistic well I think it this
is a huge question now because it comes
to the issue how do we get out of this I
mean this is very scary where we are now
this is a very severe global recession
and we want to get out of it as quickly
as possible so how do we do that well we
all recognize though we're not doing a
very good job that we have to fix the
financial system we have to recapitalize
it or make it sound in some way
governments are struggling with that I
would say no one has been fully
successful yet including unfortunately
the United States but nobody has but
that's one thing we have to do we're
going to have to help hugely over
indebted households because there are
lots of bankrupt people and we're going
to have to fix that but there's also
this very big issue as you rightly say
about the demand expansion in the world
in the future now if we think about it
if we assume there's no change in the
surplus countries assume we continue
with the sort of world we've had before
well you think about the u.s. a point
I've made in previous columns the UK is
essentially the same you've got a large
current account deficit because the
structure of your economy after many
years of specialized it you don't have
product
much tradable goods in particular so
once you get to full employment you tend
have a very large current account
deficit as excess demand so the question
you have to ask yourself what could
generate excess demand in the United
States on that scale again but it's not
going to be the household sector which
is very badly and indebted and needs
disabled it's very unlikely to be the
corporate sector in this situation so
what's going to happen it's clear what's
going to happen is the u.s. is going to
run to sustain demand enormous fiscal
deficits 10% perhaps even twelve percent
of GDP unimaginable numbers now for a
short period of time of course the US
can run fiscal deficits of that scale
but it's very risky you're going to pile
up enormous amounts of fiscal bed so to
stop this one going on either there has
to be a huge pickup in domestic demand
in the u.s. going back to the bubbles I
don't see how you can do that easily
this was I think the last big private
sector bubbles or the u.s. external
balance has to improve it's a matter of
definition if the US and UK and all
these other countries are going to have
to have better external balances Mort
about somebody else if we have dynamic
growth in the world we don't want to
compete in depression that will be no
beggar my neighbor policy that used to
be called you want expanded demand in
the rest of the world well who are in
the best position to expand demand
obviously countries with very strong
balance of payments positions with very
strong current account surpluses and
reserves countries like Germany or Japan
or China if they don't expand amount
relative to supply I think we are the
danger that we sort of chronic excess
capacity in the world chronic
deflationary pressure if you like the
whole world starts looking like Japan in
the 1990s that's sort of my worry even
with printing all the money that is sort
of my worry of what might happen and the
Japanese are printed money like man and
they've still remained like this so we
do have to expand amount now understand
completely if you take the gaze of China
which is simply the most important
single country that they can't change
their structure of their economy the
structure of demand overnight except
through a massive fiscal boost which is
what they're now doing they are actually
engaged in a huge investment
graham and in the short run that's the
right thing to do in the long run
however I think it is right for the
Chinese to try to absorb more of their
production at home and rebalance their
economy with more service production
which would generate also much more jobs
they have not done a good job of
generating jobs recently because the
development path has been quite capital
intensive much too much dependent on
investment and household disposable
income is only forty percent of GDP
which is why they're not benefiting
fully so I what I suggested in in the
piece you mentioned which I produced as
a blog during the World Economic Forum
in Davos is China should forget having a
GDP target instead of having it sort of
eight percent of growth GDP toe it
should have a real domestic demand
target you should think of the of its
policy in terms of generating real
domestic demand GDP will follow and I
suggested if you said they should try
and grow real domestic demand at twelve
percent a year for five years that will
solve the problem will help the world
and it would make the Chinese themselves
better off now I recognize this is a
huge challenge but the first step to
meeting the challenge is to define the
problem and I think that's the right way
to define the problem I think there are
similar difficulties in Japan they have
a loud domestic demand to languish now
for set 19 years since nineteen nineteen
they've got to fix that Germany has a
similar problem there are a number of
other smaller countries if this problem
is not fixed I don't really see how we
get out of this at least in the near
term without these monstrous fiscal
deficits in the US and UK and a number
of other developed countries as the
source of demand and that's going to be
politically very difficult and
ultimately I think unsustainable so the
thing that worries me most is not the
clearing up of the financial mess though
that's a big issue or even the clearing
up of the over indices of the household
thing that worries me most is as it were
where is the demand coing going to come
from to sustain rapid growth in the
world economy in the next ten years or
so and for that to happen I don't think
we can repeat a pattern in which we've
been so dependent on excess demand from
the households of a limited number
rich countries especially I think what
is one of sin in the united states that
the tax credit as stimulus to have to
before spending it didn't work people
are hanging on to their money because we
want to detach that day rather than go
and splurge in the shopping mall
absolutely but same thing is happening
though in china i gather the chinese
some city governments are giving out
coupons right to consumer coupons and
people are trying to turn that into cash
and hold hanging on to that i'm sure
that's true so risk aversion yeah so
people are afraid to go to the shopping
mall that is right that's one thing and
second thing of course is that there's
so many dead bang still walking so how
do you so [ __ ] banks and actually
create possibility of people getting
credit from the banks as it is in a war
right now my view on the first of these
questions I'm I don't think the fact
that people are saving a lot is so bad
because people do have to reduce their
debt I mean it's quite reasonable and
the if we help them to do that without
inflation that's not a bad thing but
there's no doubt in my mind this I know
has been a huge almost religious debate
here in the united states that in the
short run in these conditions it makes
most sense for to expand the forms of
spending by the government which are
immediate so and some of which goes to
people i mean unemployment compensation
of course you're going to lead a lot
more of that to sustain people demand in
this country giving money directly to
state and local government so they can
continue to employ teachers and and
firefighters all the rest of it so there
are things that you can do which will
sustain spending and if necessary in
present circumstances the government can
simply borrow from the central bank
there's no problem about inflation to
support this form of spending so the
short run that's I think what you want
to do if you provide tax cuts in the
present conditions I would expect most
of it to be saved I mean that seems to
me inevitably that would be the worst
thing the way I put it it just means if
that's what's going to happen the
stimulus bill the total deficit has to
be even bigger because you want to to
offset the fact that so much of it is
going to
be safe that is that is I think an
inevitable part of this story now on the
banks on the banks this is a very
controversial issue too and I've written
about this very very recent I'm very
very very recently and you have to start
I think with the first thing is to try
and work out what's the problem what is
really the problem and the truth is we
are still disagreeing on this there are
some people but a lot of people who
would say that the very low prices of
the assets the banks are holding which
is what's driving their insolvency
largely just result of panic if people
understood the true underlying value of
these assets they wouldn't be so
cautious it wouldn't be so frightened
the prices of these assets would rise
and the banks would appear quite solvent
and those people are the people who
suggest that a real job is to find some
way of being able to market these toxic
assets again let mr. Geithner's plan is
very much directed at that though how it
would work is quite obscure there are
other people and I'm one of them who say
assume the worst it's very likely the
banks are insolvent because these assets
are just bad and the certainly other
people the investors think they're
insolvent so they think that they have
to be recapitalised there has to be a
recapitalisation program there are it's
very very difficult to persuade the
private sector to recapitalize
institutions and have no idea what
they're worth and because they have no
idea what their assets all are worth but
all the experience so far has been very
very bad so unless you can find a real
price for these assets pretty soon it's
going to be very difficult to get the
private sector to recapitalize and we're
talking hundreds of billions possibly
even a trillion dollars or more so
enormous sums so that means that they're
essentially only two other ways of
dealing with this one is a sort of both
involve a sort of bankruptcy process but
the bankruptcy process can be
done either by injecting government
capital nationalize them you take out
the bad assets and put them in a bad
bank you nationalize you put in public
capital and you refloat the institutions
this is very much what the Swedes state
in the early 1990s there is a variant of
that in which you take the bat you leave
the bad assets in the old bank in sort
of dies and you create a good bank with
the good asset so a new institution
there's a little question of whether you
move assets into a good bank or move
assets into a bad bank that's the sort
of secondary question is quite
interesting but it's a secondary but the
alternative way of recapitalising them
is an absolutely standard bankruptcy
process but here for a lot of
institutions simultaneously and that
would essentially you put them into
bankruptcy you would eliminate the
shareholders equity because it's
worthless and you would really you would
transform some poor proportion of the
bonds held on dense the banks interred
equity so the bondholders end up owning
the bank that's a very common bankruptcy
process and then again you would have a
recapitalised bank and it will be off
and free those are a scene it seems to
me essentially the alternative at the
moment nobody around the world has been
prepared to do either of these things on
a suitable scale because it seems to me
nobody has been prepared to recognize
how big the losses actually are and also
the these old Shibboleth about
nationalization yes it's still so strong
that you cannot use that word the
android hope to be reelected but what is
so strange is people but they're not
very happy but people are prepared to
accept large public subsidies to private
institutions well i would call some of
them even bribes to private issue which
have been i misused and in some cases I
would say abused but they are very
unwilling to actually just say well we
own it because we are providing the risk
capital the reality though is that at
the moment the taxpayer is bearing the
risk I mean it's clear so whether you
call whatever you call it the risk
capital is provided by the taxpayer my
view is if the tank space
provides the risk capital the taxpayer
or the taxpayers Representatives has to
exercise managerial control otherwise
you will know that the private sector
will exploit this as indeed they clearly
did in the last quarter of last year
when you look at these grotesque bonuses
which were earned in loss-making
institutions using basically government
money now the crucial thing to say this
isn't nationalization in the long run
we're going to nationalize bangs it's
just a national ly imposed debt
restructuring that's all it is the aim
is to provide private monitor it's a
short-term now if you are really
concerned about this and it's difficult
to refloat the institutions back into
the into the capital markets quickly i
made a suggestion which I see was picked
up this morning by Nick Kristof in the
New York Times which is just give the
shares to all the American people if you
want and then it's not nationalized the
aim is definitely not to have
nationalized banking system I I share
fully the view that that will be a
terrible thing the question is how do
you restructure as bad banks that all
the experience we've had a banking
crisis around the world which I do
discuss in this book and they've been
more than a hundred really big banking
crises in the last 30 years though this
is of course much the biggest it's a
global one is you mustn't leave zombie
banks in existing zombie banks kill the
economy either they take unreasonable
risk or worse they don't dispose of
their assets and come clean with their
balance sheets and they don't expand
credit they don't do anything with their
money the zombie banks and the assets
they have have to be liberated and
that's an essential policy task okay the
last caution you about 40 years ago
honey came to our studios I think we
discussed your book why globalization
works so now it looks like it didn't
work so what went wrong well the only
thing I can say my in my
a favor is the chapter on Finance which
I've much developed in this book was the
most skeptical of all the chapters it
was the one which said I said it very
clearly in that book finance is
something that has clearly gone wrong
we've had a lot of financial crises we
have to learn from this some of the
lessons and I also discussed the
possibility of a very briefly of a major
global crisis now I have to admit that
at that time I wrote this book in 2002
and 2003 I did not that's probably a
lack of imagination for see a bubble on
this scale leading essentially to the
demolition or at least an immense crisis
of a type i haven't seen in my lifetime
so since the Second World War affecting
the core financial systems of the world
and I'd assume that these will continue
to be predominantly emerging market
financial crises and I focus as I do
here very much on what you do what you
do with emerging market financial crisis
now of course it has become something
global and that I I thought actually I
thought then it was more likely that
we'd be threatened by some geo political
or military event we were concerned
about terrorism nuclear terrorism that
war that was something I discussed at
great length as a risk though I did not
actually talk about a financial danger
now what we've learned is that the
financial crisis the financial system is
even more unstable more dangerous more
fragile than I thought on the global
level I don't think it undermines the
case for globalization in trade and
foreign direct investment and for the
big huge gains that have been made by
countries like China and India
containing in you know billions of
people as a result of globalization it
seems to be quite clear the gains a huge
and if we not look now at the d
globalization it's all very frightening
and it could go really wrong we could
have terrible protectionism and we
hundreds of millions of people I think
will lose hope for the future I think
will be a tragedy if that happened but
that all that shows is that my concern
about the financial system should have
been even stronger than it was that's
why I wrote this book and that the issue
now
of one reconstructing the global
financial system so that it works better
so we don't have a crisis like this
again soon and I discussed that in this
book and I have more ideas since then
and that we deal with this big domestic
demand balance problem the the problems
of capital flowing uphill which I have
been concerned about now for many years
these are really even more important now
policymakers the big policy makers of
the world President Obama and the others
in developing countries too that's why
the g20 s become so important countries
like India and China are also evolved we
have to construct together a system that
works better in this respect it's an
incredible priority if we do that I
think we can keep globalization going
but if not we may revert to the most
terrible disasters which we saw in the
thirties by American or British job by
British oil and it could get much worse
than that that's just pretty mild but it
could get much worse if a year from now
or two years from now the world economy
is still syncing an unemployment is over
ten percent and in China you know the
economy is very weak and and the
unemployment is very weak everywhere
governments will become populists and
populist governments will become
nationalist and we could have terrible
global conflicts so this is very very
dangerous and we have to deal with it
now that's why I've been you know I feel
by my standards in my writing I've been
almost hysterical and I try to be very
reasonable and calm in what I write I
think it's one should be but I do think
the situation we are now we have been in
since last September is a critical
situation in all the respects we talked
about policymakers have to deal with it
if they deal with it quickly and
urgently and cooperatively very
important it's a global problem we need
global solutions then I think we can get
through this over the next few years and
if not we'll be in a different world but
it won't be a better one one that not
Martin enough thank you very much it's a
pleasure thank you